ah
i recognize that character where's that
from
[Applause]
that's so good
[Music]
hello i'm andy circus and i am playing
what happens next with lad bible
okay here we go
trotting i don't know
20 sheep run across the circuit
okay
i hope that's the case a dog leaps up
and sits on the back of the horse
think it could be that
the horse lets out a huge fart causing
it to leap upwards
i hope it's that well i actually think
it is b a dog leaps up and sits on the
back of the horse but let's see
oh
wow
i can almost smell it from here
god that well that's not what they teach
in dressage surely
that's
that was extraordinary
here we go so this all looks very benign
and uneventful
uh here we go
my goodness
a flock of seagulls descends on the
woman's gum
i hope it's that i really hope it's that
a huge rat runs onto her mat
oh my god
okay and
her massive dog plonks itself down on
her head
please please please be the flock of
seagulls
oh my god
surely that's a shocker that is a [ __ ] i
really was not expecting
that dog is a well-endowed dog
i am shocked i know not what to say
ah
i recognize that character where's that
from
a baby spits food out and all over the
phone
probably because of the performance of
the cg character uh here we go uh baby
does an impressive gollum impression
baby screams in abject horror
i think the baby spits out food all over
the phone
[Applause]
that's so good
oh my god that's hilarious
man looks like he's running i'm gonna
take a running lump uh running jump
ah
he splits his shorts revealing his rear
end to the world
his friend pulls away the planks and he
falls forward oh that would be so mean
he does a backflip and breaks through
the floorboards it's got to be there i'm
from sorry i think it's c i think it
feels like that that the where he's at
at the moment
i think there's a backflip involved
oh
yes
god that was amazing
he looks like how did he not hurt
himself
that's unbelievable
okay uh
wheelbarrow
dog mattress oh my gosh okay
well that dog's gotta jump in the
wheelbarrow surely
he's being chased
okay all right uh
dog turns and attacks the wheelbarrow
man trips and somersaults over the
wheelbarrow that would be interesting
son runs in and kicks ball onto barrow
in one
i think i think a dog turns and attacks
the wheelbarrow
no i think man trips and somersaults
over the wheelbarrow
yes
yes
success
andy for this game unfortunately you
lost
[Music]
i'm hoping that snake turns around and
bites him what's he doing dragging that
snake leave it be man just let it
slither off you have to be an idiot to
get killed by a python i'm sorry to
anyone who's got killed by a python but
you have to be a proper idiot